THREATS, AND YES, EVEN VIOLENCE.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW, CHRISSY BROWN,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MOUNTAINEER PREGNANCY SERVICES
IN ASHEVILLE, NORTH CAROLINA,
ONE OF THE CLINICS ATTACKED THIS
WEEK.
I SAW THE WAY IT LOOKED, YOU
KNOW, THE PHOTO OF THE FRONT OF
THEIR CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTER
THAT YOU WORK FOR.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, IT'S
PRETTY AWFUL, WILL YOU BE COWED
BY THESE -- THE ACTIONS, THESE
CRIMINAL ACTIONS OF THE
RADICALS?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING US ON,
LAURA.
ALTHOUGH WE TAKE THIS AS A
DIRECT THREAT TO OUR PREGNANCY
CENTER, WE WILL NOT BACK DOWN.
WE CONTINUE TODAY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO A FULL DAY OF
CLIENTS.
WE WILL BE DOING TOMORROW
PROVIDING CLIENTS, WE JUST HAVE
TO MAKE A FEW ALTERATIONS IN
LIGHT OF DOORS BEING BROKEN AND
THAT TYPE OF THING, BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE DOING WHAT WE DO.
>> Laura: AND THE YOUNG WOMEN
WHO COME FOR HOPE AND AN
ALTERNATIVE TO ABORTION -- UP AT
THE GREAT PRIVILEGE OF SPEAKING
A LOT OF CRISIS PREGNANCY
CENTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY, JUST
AMAZING ANGELS AMONG US WHO WORK
AT THESE CENTERS.
BUT ARE THEY -- YOU WORRIED THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO BE SCARED,
WHICH I THINK IS PART OF THE
PLAN HERE?
THEY DON'T WANT THESE YOUNG
WOMEN SEEKING THE SERVICES, THEY
PREFER THEM TO GO FOR THE
QUICKIE ABORTION DOWN THE ROAD
AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> CORRECT.
OUR FIRST THOUGHT THIS MORNING
WAS OUR CLIENTS.
WE HAD TO FIRST ASSESS IF WE
COULD EVEN SEE THEM.
WHEN WE REALIZED WE COULD, THEN
WE GOT ON THE PHONE WE START
CALLING AND SAID HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENED, BUT WE WANT YOU TO
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE SAFE, WE
HAVE POLICE PRESENCE, AND OUR
CLIENTS CAME IN.
SO IT JUST MEANS WE ARE
HAVING -- WE ARE GOING TO GET
THE PAINT OFF AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND GET THE GLASS
CLEANED UP AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
WE WANT A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
CLIENTS, VOLUNTEERS, AND STAFF.
>> Laura: AN ANARCHIST
GROUP -- YOU SAW THAT -- SENT A
TWEET WITH A LINK TO A
PROCLAMATION FOR JANE'S REVENGE
AND THE NIGHT OF RAGE.
IT READ "WE NEED TO GET ANGRY,
WE NEED TO EXPRESS THIS MAP IS
FULLY AND WITH FEROCITY.
WE NEED TO QUIT CONTAINING
OURSELVES, THE NEXT STEP IS
CARRYING THAT ANGER OUT INTO THE
WORLD AND EXPRESSING IT
PHYSICALLY."
THAT'S ABOUT AS CLOSE AS IT
COMES TO A VIOLENT THREAT.
AGAIN, WHEN THE ROE DECISION
ULTIMATELY IS HANDED DOWN BY THE
SUPREME COURT, ARE YOU GOING TO
BE TAKING EXTRA PRECAUTIONS FOR
YOUR OWN SAFETY AND THE SAFETY
OF YOUR CLINIC GIMMICK
>> WE STARTED LAST YEAR TAKING
EXTRA PRECAUTIONS FOR SAFETY IN
OUR CENTER, SO WE HAVE ALREADY
PUT STEPS INTO PLACE.
WITH TODAY'S EVENT, WE HAVE BEEN
REASSESSING EVERYTHING TODAY.
WE DO FEEL THERE ARE A FEW
ADDITIONAL STEPS THAT WE ARE
TAKING, WE ARE IN CONSTANT
MEDICATION TONIGHT WITH OUR
LOCAL POLICE WHO HAVE BEEN
WONDERFUL WITH US TODAY.
AND THERE WILL PROBABLY BE
ADDITIONAL STEPS WE NEED TO
TAKE.
>> Laura: THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING OUT TONIGHT, THERE ARE
A LOT OF FOLKS OUT THERE WHO ARE
TRULY FRIGHTENED BY WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY SAVING LIVES AND